in 1792 a chemist named adalynn received
a sample of a mysterious black rock from
this now-closed swedish mine as far to
having to be coal it was called it abide
after Italy the nearby town nowadays we
understand the basics of chemistry we've
named all the natural elements and we've
made our own but back then it wasn't
just there were gaps in the periodic
table it's that there wasn't a periodic
table at all hey Ronny Gavin was given
the rock from this mine Lavoie VA known
as the father of chemistry had only just
published the paper setting forward the
theory of elements and even he
speculated those elements might include
light and caloric an invisible fluid
that explained how heat worked it was
plausible at the time the way to work
out whether something with a new element
was basically do stuff to it and see
what happened which is still the
technique today it's just that do stuff
to it is now defined as smash atoms
together in a particle accelerator and
tractor bits of radiation given out as a
result decay per century though it was
things like heat stuff up and see what
wavelengths of light come out or put
different voltages of electricity
through it and see how the current
changes the big problem was that the
samples that those chemists were working
with won't anything close to pure and
they couldn't know how to purify
something that hadn't been discovered
yet so they had to work out was that a
new element that they were looking at or
just a combination of known ones so
papers were published that turned out
later to be completely wrong and we're
corrected by others which is great
because that's how science works it also
means that a lot of people and places
that might have had elements named after
them were disappointed Canada Norway
Russia unlucky here though are though a
discoveries to be made through the 19th
century Gavilan and other chemists found
that the black rocks from this mine had
not one but four new elements that were
completely unknown designers and they
were all named after here atrium terbium
erbium and terbium making this small
town in sweden the only place in the
world with four elements named after it